singer/songwriter Big Time star Grammy
winner Melissa Etheridge Kansas City
Chiefs fan joining us on the program
come on in Melissa
like a big time introduction you kick
off your annual holiday tour November 24
find all the dates ticket information
visiting the website Melissa Etheridge
dot-com two Grammy Awards 15 nominations
and the stat of the day aunt well that's
really I can't tell you that that's
right up there with the Oscar and I
thought it was so cool that you did it
cuz like when you know we just called
because I said you know who taught Brad
Pitt how to fish you know fly fish in a
river runs do it and I said Melissa
Etheridge and Fritzi goes maybe I'll
call her I should do this on short
notice I hope she's a huge sports fan
and big Dan Patrick show Fame but let's
give it a shot if she says yes it would
be pretty awesome on short notice and
she agreed to do and she's very very
cool oh absolutely I swear when I die
it's gonna say she taught Brad Pitt fly
fish on my on my stone but whether it's
true or not it's still a great I mean I
didn't teach him I just he was
auditioning he that was back it was like
his second or third movie was back when
he had to audition how good-looking was
Brad Pitt back there oh you know what he
was not only good-looking he was really
sweet we were both from the Midwest we
were both huge Kansas City Chiefs fans
we watched football together he's
Missouri
yeah he's Missouri and I'm Leavenworth
Kansas just on the other side okay yeah
yeah we talked about it the last time
that your dad kind of introduced you to
the Kansas City Chiefs oh man my dad a
huge athlete he got into keek it was
super poor born and raised in Missouri
super poor got a an athletic scholarship
to a college and he became a teacher and
he was always grateful for that he was a
high school coach in Kansas and he
actually took the basketball team to
state and kind of so so I grew up with a
lot of sports and he loved the Kansas
City Chiefs and when their big year you
know lynnie Dawson and everybody and in
69 and Hank Stram and and then and and
I'm you know eight nine years old very
impressionable and I just thought that
was greatest thing in the world
of course we've never done that sense
yeah sure
this year so very exciting okay but you
wrote a song about Alex Smith in the
shoes I did well I written a song about
a lot of my exes what made you write a
song about Alex Smith well I was well I
had it was was that last year or no was
two years ago when he really really came
through and you know and and and Twitter
had just I just gotten on Twitter which
is a lot of fun and um I took a picture
of me in front of Alex and it was when
Alex had you know gone all out and done
a it got that touchdown and I was like
oh Alex Smith he might be the only guy I
want to write a song about and the haha
that was funny and then I went on
another it was another sport show okay
it's okay okay there's a good morning
football and I went on that and they
said hey well you know did you write
that song so I had to better write up a
little Alex Smith song what what are
some of the lyrics do well it was Alex
Smith I love you and oh okay I I don't
really know that's I don't know why
because I'm not even bi or something
like that
see now Holmes is like a new lover you
know you're like you're like I don't
know this is very exciting and you know
it's been so perfect but when's the shoe
gonna drop sort of thing you know that's
that's when your can say cheese fan
you're always like oh great but wait
till we get to the playoffs you know
that's when we always blow it but asthma
Holmes
can you write something that rhymes with
Mahone no oh you have to
mahomes mutt no no Malone's no it
doesn't work I'm sorry
you can work shopping you've got time
had I been at my house I was actually
gonna kind of think about a little a
little one but you know then I had to
leave my house a few days ago and yeah
evacuated we're still evacuating Amanda
do you know what's that well I know that
there's I mean so many of lost so much I
don't want to bring everybody down but
um you know I my neighborhood is Hidden
Hills and it's it's right like in
between the two fires so we're hoping
that they both go the other way but you
know it is what it is in its California
and it's you know so you just grab and
go yeah you know it's funny when you I
don't know if you've ever been evacuated
what do you
what do you grab exactly I stood there
and I have a lot of guitars hanging on
my home a lot of guitars that mean a lot
to me and you know you you look in your
house and you go oh my god what what do
you take with you and I ended up not
taking any of them I was like you know
what
everything can be replaced I grab my
kids and my wife and were like you know
that's what matters and we all got in
the car and went okay whatever happens
happens do you have a lot of guitars
that were gifts gifts no I had to buy
all my I wish my guitars were gifts oh
so you didn't like you don't collect
them from like you know athletes will
exchange jerseys oh no like you guys
don't do anything now wouldn't that be
cool yeah why wouldn't you why wouldn't
I like hey bruce here's my guitar no
it's kind of like clothes i guess but no
that's what you guys do is jerseys no we
don't we don't that's a great idea
though maybe I should you know Mike what
yes I did I gave a guitar to Crystal
Bowersox who was on American Idol she
won well she was second place but she
got a she had a guitar with my signature
on it so in the end I did give her her
guitar but no no one yeah we just say to
Springsteen hey Bruce but you don't say
can you just say hey could I have one of
your guitars I don't think I would ever
have no that's like dude can I have your
shoes yes yeah you got so many music
here's my favorite question musicians
how do you know when a song is done oh
wow it's kind of like a painting you
just gotta go that's it you guys I saw
for you know 30 40 years and you have to
you have to kind of trust yourself
enough you have to go okay this this
sounds good I do edit I believe a lot in
you know you you put something down and
then you you try to get the least words
to sound the best you know the best
thing and then you got a step back and
go okay that's it and sometimes I'll
listen to something from 20 years and
going her I could have done a little bit
better but you got to let it go you got
to say that's that's that but it used to
be that it would be like two and a half
minutes three minutes was as long as you
could go to get radio play and I had
mentioned Queen came up with Bohemian
Rhapsody
and that was six minutes and they were
told it's not gonna get radio play and
then the video came out and all of a
sudden people went gaga it's so funny
the length of the song is always a an
issue when when it was radio now it's
not radio anymore I didn't have to worry
about radio ready was very very
different but back then I mean you had
to stairway to heaven that was the
bathroom song the guy the DJ would would
put it on and he'd run out and go to the
bathroom I had one of my well Freebird
yeah the next same thing in a got a
davido right so one of my one of my
songs it was actually really famous in
Canada was my live version of like the
way I do is about 11 minutes long and so
you know that caught on in some places
but you know you just you stick to about
four minutes is about all you can really
push someone what's the your favorite
cover that you've ever done oh it has to
be piece of my heart Janis Joplin that
one yeah I was setting that on the
Grammys I got to sing that I was bald
head a little but you can pull that off
with your voice like like it's weird
when when you had when somebody did I'm
trying to think who it was they did
landslide by Stevie Nicks yeah Dixie
Chicks yeah it's and it's kind of tough
when you get there you know Billy Corgan
did it too I think
covered it Mike's like man it's
dangerous to go there cuz Stevie Nicks
has that what yeah you got a really if
you're gonna cover a song you gotta
bring something to but you can't imitate
it and that don't see the problem that
people have is you're trying to sound
like that person yeah so I I mean I
started singing piece of my heart when I
was playing in the bars back you know in
the 80s and so I would sing at night
after night and and you just kind of
grow into your own version of it and so
by the time I sang it on the Grammys I
was like oh I can do this in my sleep
you just rock it did you ever have one
of those crazy tours where you were
lucky to come back home what was lucky
to come back oh oh you mean barely got
through it yeah like you know it was we
hear all these legendary you know
partying stories you know what
it's funny I um when I was when I
finally got my I finally got my record
deal when I was like 27 and that's just
like old and you know rock and roll time
so I had I had been through all that
sort of let me try this let me do that
stuff and I realized that I really
wanted my career and I really respected
it and I didn't I didn't go crazy I was
you know I I mean I'm a woman first off
they're just you know I'm lucky to be
part of the club hey you know and and so
I I didn't I didn't go crazy and do
stuff like that but that's boring come
on enough my lifestyle and everything
you know I'm weird enough as it is did
you were you ever with a band that was
well yeah I saw some people crash and
burn of course I remember I was in the
beginning I opened it was 1988 I did a
tour in Europe with Huey Lewis and the
news and and Bruce Hornsby in America I
owned the range yeah boo storms me the
ranger open for Little Feat did some
[ __ ] yeah and did some shows with I've
you know I've done a lot of I've opened
for Bob Dylan you know I played with Van
Morrison it was down there so he was he
was in a bad way
they had to like walk him but he there's
someone who was I don't know if he
doesn't anymore this was in the late
this is like 1989 1990 and he was he was
in a bad way yeah but didn't he find
religion back then I hope so yeah I
think so
that we used to live in science but you
did you get to hang with Bill no you
couldn't even look at Dylan he's one of
those backstage don't even look yeah
that always bums me out because they're
like when you hear that one no you can't
mean Prince hata you know you can't even
look at him sort of thing you hear those
stories from all the roadies and stuff
wait were you around Prince and you
weren't allowed to look at him oh yeah
that was like backstage at the Grammys
it's like you know there's always the
backstage at the Grammys you're allowed
to look you know there was always that
like same with Michael Jackson there
with there's just like a couple that
yeah they're like there but you're doing
there they are they just passed by yeah
oh come on I so never wanted to be that
I you're not again I grew up in Kansas
my dad's
like be grateful for everything you have
so I'm like I do not look directly at
Melissa
Thomas no matter my roadies will do that
I will show up at a place to play and
and they'll have told everyone don't
look at her and I'll notice I'm like
what's this song you wish you had
written oh I wish I'd written in your
eyes by Peter Gabriel I'll light the
heat or thunder road by Bruce
Springsteen you know and you wonder what
but you only have so many songs in you
right I hope not oh by block but but the
stones like the stones had so much and
then they don't have songs yeah anymore
like it that's always strange like well
I'm trying to still I I have a new album
coming out at the beginning of the year
and you try to be relevant but what's I
think what happens is there's a certain
energy that we have in our 20s and maybe
30s that's all like I want this I want
that or you know and and you people are
breaking your heart and you can you can
afford to you know go through lovers and
stuff you know nowadays we don't have as
much energy or money and so now what I'm
writing about of course when you have
children when you have a steady
relationship I'm not writing you know
I'm the only one you know but I but you
want to write relevant things so I think
what happens is just age and time sort
of changes are it's like what
Springsteen you know you still want to
listen to him he's not born to run
anymore but but you know he's got
something to say but I think the
gunslinger with my homes like like a
rockabilly yeah oh I know I know it find
a hand my guitar Ida do you have a
guitar do you have a guitar I gotta see
what kind of guitar you okay yeah oh God
deciding to bring it what the heck oh
where did you get this I'm sorry brought
this to you it looks like cheap trick
Rick Nielson Lord I don't even in tune
someone knows how to make tuna
[Music]
see you got like a gunslinger you wanna
[Music]
see but now I can't run with my home's
you know the hardest thing you write it
or have the music oh the music is easy
cuz you can go what does it sound like
he he plays like this you know I reek
ill Travis Kelce hill okay Chelsea Hill
and hunt he's got so many weapons
[Music]
[Laughter]
there's so much fun to watch can you do
now I'm gonna have to I'm gonna have to
come back I'm gonna have to come back
and have you in right so we got we have
the music yeah the music now but I gotta
I gotta think of the clever couplets
alright do you want to do a live version
of a stat of the day before we I think I
should okay hold on let me give the
formal full introduction here
it's Melissa Etheridge singer-songwriter
she kicks off her annual holiday tour on
November 24th you can find all the dates
ticket information visiting her web site
Melissa Etheridge calm when a couple of
Grammys got an Oscar yeah got an Oscar
as well and she's got it waiting for a
Heisman it's just not I think my dreams
of the Heisman are gone know you're
ready for step of the day hey here we go
[Music]
this is the start of the day
[Applause]
awesome thank you for coming in thank
you what a pleasure you really made my
day for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]